rose and it's my great pleasure to
welcome to the academy theater tonight
our writers scott alexander and larry
karazewski
christoph waltz
amy adams
and director tim burton
scott and larry yes yes sir how did you
discover the story of margaret and
walter king
we were strolling through a museum
no
we were
reading a book called the encyclopedia
of bad taste
we were working on a a rewrite 11 years
ago
uh a science fiction movie about a
a perfect planet of higher intelligence
many galaxies away that gets destroyed
when a bunch of pop culture debris from
earth finds its way to this planet
and
i think they should have made the movie
it was a funny script yeah
and it was things like emcee hammer
albums and stuff like that and you know
you know
coco puffs and gilligan's island and
disco outfits and we're looking through
this book and there was a two-page
article on margaret walter keane
and it was just such a crazy story and
we love
sort of stories that happen in in the in
the margins of pop culture stuff that
didn't get a lot of publicity but that's
really kind of quirky and interesting
this is a great story
it had these these themes of high art
and low art
that had really interesting themes about
female empowerment and a woman sort of
coming out of that
mid-century
50 suburbia version of who the woman is
and who the who the uh who the
man is in the family
and uh and margaret walter just seemed
like incredible characters
so we started researching the story
and looking up old newspapers 10 years
ago 11 11 years ago yes i wish it were
only 10 years ago
what happened next uh what happened next
was we did a lot of research and we
figured out this is a movie we really
wanted to make and we had to uh but but
when doing the research we were just
finding the sort of the public story the
sort of the walter keane story uh that's
where we discovered dick nolan for
example because walter
really was in this guy's gossip column
almost three times a week it was insane
how many times walter was in this but we
got the walter keane story and we knew
that we knew that he was walter keane
was one of our kind of guys he was a
larry flynn and edward or andy kaufman
kind of one of these blowhards who just
like you know is a self-promoter but we
also knew that for this particular movie
he would probably be the antagonist
rather than protagonists so we uh we
knew we had to track down the real
margaret keane so we uh we contacted
margaret uh through a friend of ours
who's a collector and a guy named
matthew sweet and uh we went up to meet
margaret and was she living she was
living up in northern california and we
spent san francisco we spent a great
deal of time with her trying to win her
over she's she's very much like the way
amy played her she's very shy
particularly 11 years ago she was still
very worried that the world still
thought that walter keene was the
painter because she has a gallery and
people still come to the keen eyes
gallery
you know
asking about walter keane's paintings
because
because margaret won the court case but
walter didn't stop his propaganda
machine right
so he
he continued to give me interviews until
the day he died right saying he was the
painter right which was in 2000 yeah
yeah so what we had to do really was was
was ask her questions and find out the
her personal story things like the stuff
about her and her daughter was something
we didn't really know about we didn't
know how big the conspiracy was how big
the inner circle was and we found out
the inner circle really existed between
these two people you know where
literally she had to lie to her daughter
and that was the most important person
in her life and the fact that she you
know we asked her about her friends and
she said well you know i had friends at
the beginning but you know as time went
on i'm a bad liar so i didn't invite
them over or i didn't meet them for
lunch and then when they did come over
walter would yell at them and they would
leave and so within a couple years she
didn't have any friends either so this
portrait of a really isolated woman
became clear to us and uh you know we
really we spent eight months trying to
win her trust and finally she gave us
the rights because we needed the right
to her life and we also needed the
rights to her art now tim you had a
relationship with margaret keem
at the same time this was going on right
yeah but it was purely sexual
that's really how the movie got made
okay exactly
exactly
getting back to scott and larry exactly
i think i think you guys just got a
world exclu exclusive there
you won her trust
yes
why
did it take another 10 years it's it's
not easy to get an interesting
artistically ambitious movie made
we we we were being very calculated we
were actually trying to design this
movie to be easy to get made we thought
it's two great characters we're gonna
get a great actress a great actor it's
only got a few locations
and bing bong there you go and then the
money will show up and we'll be shooting
we were trying to direct it ourselves
and we kept putting it together with
different casts and different crews and
we scouted and we prepped the movie in
portland in salt lake city
in new orleans in buenos aires argentina
ladies and gentlemen
yes we we had a full production ready to
go in south america
which doubles very well for hawaii and
san francisco better than vancouver does
strangely enough um
but it was very difficult i mean here's
the thing foreign financiers would look
at the movie and they'd say oh it's got
a it's got a female protagonist it's
it's about art you know they really
thought it was good
it's a little weird yeah they they
always thought it was going to be
you know when they look at they do the
comps on movies about artists they think
of movies like pollock which is a great
was a really good film but it's a very
serious very different kind of tone than
we were going for we always saw it as a
very entertaining you know 1950s doug
circ female empowerment picture uh but
that was that that is not that easy to
get made
tim you had commissioned a portrait from
margaret yeah i don't want to go any
further no
i got to the important bits uh no but i
mean you know
parallel universe to scott larry um you
know obviously i grew up with
it was very
keen
you know we didn't have picassos or
matisses hanging in our living rooms we
had keens and
you know and even as a child i was kind
of looking at people's grown
adults living rooms seeing why do you
have this weird crying child in your
living room you know and uh
so as a pop culture enthusiast i was
always taken by you know
quite haunting images you know something
quite disturbing about them so that it
sort of remained with me and it wasn't
until about mid 1990s that i sort of
heard the story about
you know what these guys had been been
looking into and uh i also got the
chance i went to her studio and met her
and commissioned a painting and this was
before you know i knew these guys were
writing something and so
you know i just found because it was
such a a strong part of
my you know growing up in the imagery so
such a uh you know like edward this is
dynamic of what's good and what's bad
and uh you know since i've experienced
that myself quite a lot you know i felt
quite close to the material did you
imagine ever putting her
story on film
well not when i met her because she's so
you know these guys and amy is very very
shy i mean she's got almost this sort of
you know like in war of the worlds this
sort of invisible protective shield
around her it which and she's so private
she you know you you find her
reluctant to ask her things and uh
but but uh
you know once i knew that scott larry
were writing you know given the fact
that working on ed wood i knew this is
right up their street in terms of you
know finding these kind of
you know
truth is stranger than fiction type
characters
christopher i think you had a role
somehow in bringing uh tim into this
project is that
incorrect
i would never dare to say it's incorrect
i'm just not really aware of it
um
all i can say i wish i could talk half
as fast as
larry um
um no no but
it kind of
like like um interesting projects um
usually have a tendency it kind of um
condensates there's sort of a a cloud
around and then you know specific little
particles condensate the essence and it
comes together in a cluster and and
i feel that's how it happened
i i'm not really aware of a sequence of
a causality well tim when you came on
kristoff then immediately was cast as
walter well i mean it seemed like it did
happen i mean i've worked on projects
that taken ten you know it seems to
happen it's like you'd spend this all
this time and then all of a sudden it's
like okay quick let's let's do it and uh
again i've lost track of sequence but
christoph and amy it seemed to be kind
of close in terms of the time that that
that you know we all got got interested
and uh
so
yeah i mean you never quite know how
these things happen then you show up and
then you're on the set making it and low
budget doing it quickly and uh and uh
you know sometimes it's like a like a
fine wine it takes a long time to
ferment
amy when you first read this script i
know you had some apprehension about
whether margaret was the right character
for you is
it was an apprehension about margaret
per se but just where i was in my life
and what i was looking to do with my
work i
sort of started playing more confident
characters and kind of enjoying this
process of exploring this
other side of my work and um then i had
my daughter and i
was a good three year and a half years
into parenting and i read this and i
just saw margaret is a more fully
fleshed out woman and i didn't see her
as a type
so maybe i matured a little bit and i
was able to see her
um to see a lot of different sides of
her and i didn't put her in a archetype
per se and just saw her as a woman and
then i met her and tell what that
experience was like
uh it was
scary because i had heard that she was
very
shy very private and i didn't want to go
up there and like
have a list of questions although i did
have a list of questions
i really
wanted to let her reveal to me what she
wanted to reveal
and it took some time to get her to talk
really openly and and
what she revealed was
really helpful and very telling what she
didn't reveal was also very telling
so i was able to sort of glean from her
um
she opened up her gallery in her studio
she painted for me and for me what was
so important about watching paint and
people like oh you learned a pain i'm
like no
i did not i would love to i've learned
to paint like margaret but um but she
has a relationship with her paintings
and it's almost a release for her this
experience of painting and like the film
says she still paints every day that she
can when i met her she had just come out
of the hospital and she said i was
horrible i couldn't paint like nothing
about like her illness
or what was going on just she couldn't
paint and
she was really
generous and and open and
yeah she was very lovely christophe
walter was an incredible celebrity
did you utilize any of the kinds of tv
programs that he'd been on and
the kind of press
attention he was getting in terms of
shaping your
performance no absolutely not i don't
like that responsibility and also um i i
kind of
don't view what i do as sort of
imitation of
of someone or something that might be
considered by someone the real thing
i consider myself real enough
tim you mentioned this was a return to
you for low budget filmmaking where your
career began i wonder if you could talk
a little bit about because you'd been
making some pretty
large special effects uh films of late
uh what was it like i mean it was great
it was a smaller crew you know just uh
you know didn't have to worry about uh
burger king tie-ins or mcdonald's uh
things uh
didn't hear the word franchise which is
nice uh
you know it was great because it really
everybody pitch in it kind of recreated
that energy you know making like student
films or you know the early days and uh
so it was quite exhilarating and uh
you know i think the toughest thing was
uh trying to make vancouver look like
san francisco you know but but
everything else about it was was really
a beautiful fun energizing experience
how much of it was shot in san francisco
a few days yeah just three days
uh and a couple of days in hawaii
but uh but you know that's that's part
of the joy of making a film you know
everybody kind of pitching in and trying
to create something that's not really
there and uh
you know and again
you know i working with every actor in
the film i i'd never worked with and so
everyone i admired and you know since
i'm not a social person it was a great
way to meet people
so
christophe and amy could you talk about
what tim's
working process is like as a director
other than just the chance to meet with
you
after we met
i kind of clung to amy
oh no
you know
i sometimes have a tendency to be
intimidated by people very easily
and uh
i had been a long admirer of tim's work
and had met him out several times don't
know that i really talked to him kind of
looked at him and sort of like maybe
shaked my head or did something
embarrassing or tried to talk and then
kind of mumbled off into a corner which
which now that i know him like he was
like this is the mating call like he's
like
uh he's like oh that is some good stuff
what's going on there i'm all like i
really like your work and especially
like never mind like he's like oh yeah
that makes a lot of sense i don't know
what she said but
um
but uh
when i heard that this film was
happening and i had an opportunity to re
read it again i had this like
overwhelming feeling that i wanted to
play margaret and i usually follow my
instincts when i want to play a
character
it doesn't happen that often that i feel
like i have to write a director but i
wrote him and kind of pled my case to
some degree
it wasn't begging but probably
probably had i met him it would have
looked like begging and then i would
have slunk off to a corner and he would
have been like awesome
um
no i'm sorry tim but you're
here i go see and i'm gonna slink off to
a corner but uh well i was surprised
when i started working with him that i
was actually very very relaxed and i
settled into this place of
joy in my work and real discovery and i
felt like he created this universe in
which i got to existence and i know i
was playing margaret and she was a real
person and i always kept that in mind
and i honored that but i also was
existing inside the world of this
director
that was inclusive um
very very um inquisitive and joyful he
laughed with us he cried with us we felt
like we were just all in it together it
was a beautiful experience for me i was
actually laughing at you well i can
explain
any attention from you is good attention
so i'll take it
you see there's there's a special
language as you might have noticed that
you need to learn um to speak
with him
it's timmy's and
and once you get fluented in it it's
like traveling to a foreign country it
kind of opens up these most amazing
things
um
um so so so that's that's the wonderful
thing you explore
um
a foreign world once you learn how to
speak times
speaking of amazing things i think one
of the great uh
showpieces of this film is that trial
scene but uh scott larry it's true that
this wasn't even what was really there
was much much more to this trial blows
people's minds to find out that we had
to tone down the trial because
because walter keane actually did
represent himself he did cross-examine
himself yeah he he ran back and forth
yeah and uh you know how else would you
do it crosstalk
it totally makes sense completely
logical to chris um
uh yeah we read the all the hawaiian uh
you know newspapers about what went down
to trial and the judge so hated walter
keane i mean the judge was like you have
concrete between your ears you you know
he wanted to duct tape walter's mouth
um he tried to shackle him yeah so uh we
actually wrote the first draft of the
script had a lot of that stuff in there
and also walter walter kept flying in
character witnesses who kept bombing out
on the stand
they were supposed to be making walter
look good and then once they've like
done the oath on the bible then they
look at the judge they would start
telling stories against walter
no i haven't seen you paint you know
that kind of well yes you have yes you
have he actually flew wayne newton there
believe it or not
the restraint it took for us not to put
wayne newton in the script let me tell
you
uh but uh wayne newton actually later
flew out to hawaii to meet the real
margaret keane and apologize once he
actually like years later when he
actually knew the truth wayne newton
came to margaret well he has his own
airplane he does he's wayne newton he
can do whatever you want apologized in
song but that's just my secret wish
so yeah we toned it down a bit we we
didn't want to appear i mean obviously
it is a big comic set piece but it would
if we needed it it's a climax exists in
reality as well
has margaret seen the film
yes her reaction
well i mean for uh we we took her to see
we flew up to san francisco to show her
rough cut last summer uh and you know
when we when we got her right she was in
her late 70s now she's in her late 80s
she's 87 and so we really wanted her to
to see the film yeah i mean because we
were dragging this project out
you know when we met her in 2003 and we
got her to sign on the dotted line we
said a year or two right
and then we had to keep re-extending the
rights deal
and then she would call every six months
so what's happening with our movie
and then and then we would get her hopes
up oh we're going to be shooting in
portland yay and then six months later
it fell apart
and and so we just we desperately wanted
her to see the movie and
tim wasn't 100 finished with the movie
and we felt bad because tim was still
tweaking it and finishing the color
timing and the music but we just wanted
her to see the film
and um
she's she's actually going to come out
to see the movie out here which is i
mean now she she's really happy with it
it was very touching to watch her watch
the movie yeah we actually we it was a
big theater and it was her and jane and
jane's husband and the person from the
gallery and us and they wanted us to sit
right next to them but we didn't want to
do that so we sat a couple rows behind
her so we could watch her watch the
movie and uh it was you know scenes
would come on between her and and her
daughter and you'd see this like like
sort of jump in recognition and then
afterwards we went over to her and uh at
the end of the movie and she was just
weeping and she was just she felt so
touched and she she really thought more
than anything she was like oh my god it
was like being back with walter for two
hours
you know
must have made you feel good yeah no we
felt bad it's like it's like you know
it's like it's like it's like taking
tina turner to meet ike for another
session or something you know
we want to thank you all for joining us
tonight at the academy and uh thank you